disparity with the amount of labor that
women do and that men do yeah but
men make more money statistically so you
could just say the men contribute more
yeah men provide value like a dude if a
dude's paying my rent he's not doing
[ __ ] he's not doing [ __ ] around the
women
house
work so like they're also doing a
nine-to-five like maybe they're so like
what i'm saying statistically men make
more money i just so go ahead i just
wanted to ask all your statistics and
your percentages all of that where
did you find it is it in the uk is it in
the us uk and us
there's a little bit of a disparity
between the uk and u.s specifically when
it comes to divorce it's 64 percent in
the uk and it's 80 in in and who carried
out
um the government the government studies
how many women a hundred women and then
ask them about their life so do you
think do you think if you if you do
three four different studies and they
all come up to similar conclusions we
can we can say that it's around eighty
percent
yeah divorce lawyers
divorce court if we get in the
statistics from there so we can see
who's initiating the divorces like
someone has to file right exactly
it goes on record so it's 80 of women
that are fighting for divorce
how would you improve the situation for
like
i feel like you both have like heard you
know thought about this a lot like what
would you say that both men and women
can do to improve the situation
i think a financial abortion should be
legal
what do you mean what do you mean like i
think that if um women have the right to
get an abortion men should be able to
get a financial abortion so they can
sign off all rights and not pay any
child support
whoa i'd say that's one thing because
the way it is now like women are
incentivized to get kids off of rich
guys like the nba had to issue a
statement saying that women like kept
stealing condoms and i just think that
should be illegal like you shouldn't be
able to legally do drake had to put hot
sauce in here like i'd say that's one
stop this woman from getting the baby
there are women out there literally
incentivized to try and get a rich man's
baby that was just one story with drake
and one random lady and it doesn't
represent all women and so so i
understand that but i do these
interviews all the time so i'll go on
the street i'll talk to matt like i'll
talk to matt random people on the street
random people in my living room and i've
had so many guys tell me stories of
girls doing this to them go ahead and
you your guys opinions favor a certain
side so when you go out on these
ventures and you ask people you know
what you're looking for you know what
you can put and edit
are you saying we're rigging the game
now isn't it no i'm not rigging the game
but you're looking for something can you
that's why you're going out there so
you're going to speak about something
i would say i would say i get more
people that disagree to be honest when i
go out than agree so i wouldn't say i'm
like rigging the game okay but if you if
you're going to have sex with a woman
sorry
you can say sexy
woman um
[Laughter]
there isn't there is a chance that that
woman may get pregnant
like so if you have sex with a guy
there's a chance you might get pregnant
yeah yeah that's on you yeah so so if
you if you get to choose not to be a
mother he should get to choose not to be
a father
equal
equality he whose responsibility do you
think it is for getting pregnant
both of those it's yeah it's definitely
a yeah that's a yeah but women have more
to risk by getting yeah
they need to have exercise unless it's
a situation of grape you let the man
inside yeah so how was it so it's your
responsibility if you get pregnant even
though it's it's it's no i said who's
the responsibility for it to get
pregnant all of the power is within the
woman's hands you have the right to say
yes or no once you do say yes or no
you have the right to keep the baby you
have the right to either um put the baby
up for adoption you have the right to
put the man on child support we also we
also we also have birth control you can
get an iud it's like 99.99 effectively
so yeah so these aren't great though
birth control isn't great to be but i'm
saying that's a better option than what
what men have or you can require them
and you sleep with wear a condom
so it's like i'm saying we have all the
power when it comes to sex and who who
gives birth and who picks who is born
yeah nowadays a woman's i feel like a
woman's really only going to have a kid
if you like really wanted to because
there's so many ways for her to prevent
that at different stages all throughout
but i also think if there were more
support for women who do want to have
children may not have necessarily found
the right man who actually wants to have
a child with her if she was able to get
more financial support then she wouldn't
feel like she'd need to trap a man oh
but she's not going to talk
that's a horrible excuse
are you excusing a girl trying to get a
kid off of a rich guy because she
doesn't want it like i'm not trying to
excuse it but that's what you're doing
if like you know childcare is really
expensive
okay
raising the child is really expensive
and it's really hard to do on your own
right yes
you get married and do it but well if no
one wants to marry you did you know that
before
you need to you need to you need to
change your strengths well i'm saying
maybe lower your standards though
if no one other guys you like want to
marry you you're probably shooting too
high
change how you deal with it just like
just like if a dude's shooting at
victoria's secret models and they all
tell him no like he'll probably be like
oh me a joke well i feel like
what would you like just don't see any
men that you like sperm dollar yeah so
when you're asexual you don't have any
romantic or sexual interest ever you
just want a baby to live life have a kid
well isn't that selfish to bring to
bring a kid into a situation
it's it's not so you don't think
children need to to parents no well i
think they need a community i don't
think they need to pay one of the
reasons why society is broken because
women are actually literally running
around thinking that children don't need
two parents if you're a good enough
person you can teach a child
i just read you a bunch of stats showing
that
children that come from single mothers
are statistically a disadvantage in
nearly every category that's not
necessary and then you're going to tell
me oh yeah it's fine let's rate a
child's body
i don't i think i think it's equally
selfish if a dude does the same thing
like if if a dude if a dude wanted to
i don't know adopt as a single father
like i think that's selfish even if you
can't that doesn't necessarily mean you
should yeah like because you're putting
you're putting what you want about what
is best for the kid i think if you're
adopting a child whether you're a single
person or not i think that's a really
lovely thing to do because being in the
care system is not fun and if you're a
single parent it's better than having no
parent no one to look after you you've
got care workers in and out all day and
also like
i lost my train of thought but an ideal
situation would be in an ideal situation
is two parents would you not agree with
that i would i would agree that you need
a support system it doesn't necessarily
mean it needs to be two parents you
could have four parents you could have
you could have cousins and aunties who
are older do you think it's the same as
having a mom and a dad in the home i've
never had both so i have no idea i could
not compare i think if the kid has
adults who love them and show that they
love them openly and always then it
doesn't matter if it's specifically a
man and a woman or two parents that
raise them so if it's a community it's
someone that shows love so when all the
statistics that i read they never had a
father in the home there are so many
different hangouts they never had a
father in the home okay it was single
they never had a father this shows that
boys and girls need both their mother
and their father to be
fully functioning members of society who
aren't going to be rapists who aren't
going to be
prisoners who aren't going to be you
know misfits but i i see this is one of
the things that i can't understand why
women would argue
for
single them and to raise a child by
themselves and then act like it's normal
like it's gonna it's gonna benefit
society it's gonna it's not gonna
benefit society when it comes to prison
it's not gonna benefit society when it
comes to crime
so why do it i think what you've just
said is that you can't be a normal
functioning member of society if you're
raised
okay but just because you heard it
that's not what he said that's not what
he said so what he what we're saying is
it puts you at every statistical
disadvantage so why would you push that
in a society yeah i don't think
personally i'm not speaking to everyone
else i'm not pushing it but if that's
your best bet like
you know
then
that's
all you can do is your best and if
you're doing your best then like what
else can you give me
there's always
there's always a guy that's gonna marry
you like i'm sorry one out of three men
are either versions or haven't had sex
in the last year so the issue is just
like the guys that girls want don't want
them and so i think the the solution is
getting a guy on your level um i feel
like the thing with the
parents the kids the mothers i feel like
kids are just kids they would they just
arrived here they don't know anything
the only way a kid has got to be
disadvantaged from a single parent or
whatever is when they go grow up and
then they hear people talking about it
do you have a job as a kid you won't
notice who's